okay so once every year or so i find
myself struggling with a software
development problem at my day job that i
don't manage to get sow by the time that
i i head home from work for the weekend
on friday night
but i find that often putting some space
and time between myself and the job
enables me to have flashes of insight
into the problem
and i often see that the problem
is not just my problem but it's a
general problem it's a problem that any
pearl developer could have perhaps even
that any developer could have
and i think to myself
if the solution pops in my head i can
make a general solution and i can share
it with other people i can put it up on
cpan
and so i spend a weekend furiously
coding to write a new cpn distribution
that meets my needs on the day job and
meets perhaps your needs as well
so this evening i'm going to introduce
you to several of these cpn modules that
i've written over the years
right
i'll describe the original software
development problem i was facing the
high level details of the distribution
and how they solved the problem i was
facing
and each of these is a very tightly
focused thing i wrote in the weekend
that's why i call them a weekend wonder
but
none of these modules are groundbreaking
they are by my own admission modest
modules aimed at solving rather narrowly
defined problems in a satisfactory way
don't get too hung up in the details i'm
not teaching these modules tonight
what i do hope you take away from
tonight's presentation is a heightened
awareness of where writing some modest
but useful modules and sharing them can
help you
as a developer
okay
first module is called parse file
metadata from 2006 to 2012 i worked at a
large email service provider
headquartered in new york city
the team in which i work was responsible
for receiving data files in custom
formats transmitted to us by clients
over sftp
and preparing that data for loading into
a database via an api
we became very adept at elementary etl
extract transform and load
usually we opened up the header file we
opened up the the incoming file read the
header row then iterated over each
record to write a munched record to a
new file which was sent to the api
but sometimes we received data files
that had different formats
one such format had two different
sections within the file
a header section that looks like this
consisting of key value pairs
pairs which in some sense constituted
metadata
and a body section which consisted of
data records which were either delimited
or fixed with
this particular body section uh consists
of comma delimited strings
now whether in the body or the header
comments uh
start with a pound sign and they're
ignored right
our instruction was to apply business
rules to the header data
to apply business rules to the data from
the header to determine whether or not
to proceed with the processing of
records in the body of the file
if certain criteria were not met after
after processing the header we would
simply close the file and ignore the
body records
only body records would ever be
considered for presentation to the api
suppose you are told that you should
proceed to parse the body if and only if
the following conditions are met in the
header
there must be a metadata element keyed
on
the value of metadata element d must be
a non-negative integer
there must also be a metadata element
keyed on f
this file would meet all three criteria
and the program would proceed to parse
the three data records
if however the
uh
the f were commented out the file would
not qualify it would not meet the
criteria
what sub me for a long time was how to
read and parse some of the lines in the
file in one manner and then parse the
remaining lines of the file in a
different manner
and sitting at my desk at work i
couldn't clear my head enough to come up
with a solution
it was only when i got home and i
relaxed for the weekend that a solution
came to me a solution which by the end
of the weekend i had put up on cpan as
parse file metadata
tonight i'm only going to give you a
high-level oversimplified description of
parsefile metadata
you set up a constructor which you
provide and you provide the constructor
with a path to the file you want to
process
a pattern describing how to split a
header row on a delimiter and an array
of code references which spell out
whether at the end of the header rows
you should proceed to parse the body
rows
once you have parsed the header you
write another code reference specifying
how to process each record in the body
of the file
you pass that code reference to the
method called process metadata and
proceed
to refresh my memory as to how parse
file metadata's development proceeded i
consulted the changes file in the cpan
distribution
i put the first file first version up on
cpan on a sunday night
over the next two weeks i refined it
based on
my own testing and on feedback from
cpentesters.org
now it turned out that the
uh the thing that we were that i needed
this module for my day job that project
got stalled for three months
but in the meantime i showed this uh
module to one of my co-workers
and he found some errors in the
documentation and i corrected it
so
after three months it finally went into
production
so uh at this point it had been it had
been improved both by the result of
being put on cpn and by being reviewed
by my colleague
the next module text csv hashify
when i started my current job i was far
from fluent in sql
i've worked my way through an sql a
mysql book back in 2004
but from 2006 to 2012 i only had to
write sql about once a year
when i came to media
math however i had to write sql from the
get go
toward the end of 2012 i had a big
project which entailed a big overhaul of
the mapping of advertising audience
targets to regional codes
some regions such as the new nation of
south sudan were coming into the
regional coding system for the very
first time
within these new top level regions there
were
there were child regions such as central
equatoria and upper nile in south sudan
we also had regions that were getting
new code numbers such as these five
regions in australia
and we were we were creating new regions
within some existing top-level regions
now as i said i was just a beginner in
sql and i could not figure out how to do
this data migration i was just getting
lost in sub selects and temporary tables
and so forth
however
i figured out that if i
could solve the problem in perl first i
would at least have insight into the
flow that was needed to subsequently
solve the program in sql
so the
the data came into us in the form of
spreadsheets spreadsheets you can save
to csv files csv files made me think of
the cpm module called text csv
and if i get it from a csv file into
perl i can put it into a perl data
structure and i can then manipulate that
to my heart's content
i can
add new records reorder the tree do
whatever i need to do and at the end of
it i can print out that pearl data
structure by a data dumper or something
like that and i can see
it does this the data strip this is the
data structure that i need to end up
with at the end of this code of this
target migration
not only that if i print this out
and i say i think this is where we need
to end up
i can go and give it to the product
manager and she can proofread it
and
if if if i have that then i can go back
and try to solve the problem in sql
so that's what i did tech csv it's a
it's an old module but it's kept up to
date it has pure pearl and excess
version so it's fast
but its interface is a bit heavy and all
i wanted to be able to do all i needed
to do was to say this csv file
represents a postgres table the table's
primary key is whatever
and i want to turn this file into a hash
so my solution was a cpn module called
text csv hashified
this module has an object-oriented
interface but it also has a drop-dead
simple functional interface that just
says hashify this file with this primary
key and give me back a pearl hash
so what happened next
i manipulated the hash until i got the
desired final state
i printed it out and had the product
manager reviewed
right she signed off so i knew
how what the data had to end up
then i went back to sql
and instead of using pearl hashes i
created temporary tables to rep to hold
the intermediate state as i
uh added one table at one set of data
after another on the way to the final
result and finally after several months
we put this database into production and
effected this
migration
the final module that i'm going to talk
about tonight is called get reduced
tests
so the problem is
you have a very large test suite
and
it must run on a smoke testing server
for you
to
have the code reviewed or get the code
merge the code into production
but what happens if your smoke server is
having problems what if your smoke
server is taking three times as long as
it was doing last week right
that's a problem
and we faced that problem here a couple
months ago
and what i figured was you know we run
this enormous test suite but
for any given branch
in the repository that i'm working on
i'm only concerned with a few files
and so
maybe what i could do is i could
temporarily reduce the size of the test
suite and get that through jenkins since
that was the smoke server that was
causing its problems get that through
jenkins quicker
and so what i've
figured out was that if i created a
branch that was exactly like the branch
i was working on but he had a lot fewer
tests and sent that off to the smoke
server i could get results sooner
so
in the case we do this in the pearl five
core distribution
to send something to a smoke server we
create a branch that starts with
smoke me right here at media math if we
push a branch to the smoke server and we
precede it with topic
jenkins kicks off a smoke test run
so
i wanted to automate the creation of a
sm of a branch with a smaller number of
tests and i wrote get reduced tests
it's basically a command line utility
called reduced tests to which you give
a directory the branch you're working on
the name of your remote
the test files that you want to include
in the small test suite or alternatively
the files that you wish to exclude
the prefix that kicks off this the smoke
server prefix for the branch name
and maybe some verbosity as well
and i would say that since august i've
used this repeatedly on the day job
not just in the case where jenkins is
giving us problems but also where for
a variety of purposes i want to be able
to
run and look at just a few tests at
one time
so
three modules they have similarities
they're all weekend wonders
version 0.01 got to cpan by monday
morning
but they're modest modules they have a
tight focus small number of files and
functions and as a result i get high
test coverage
but there are differences among them too
uh get reduced tests and tech csv
were met as developers tools
you could use text csv in production but
i didn't design of that i designed it to
make my work faster as a developer
parse file metadata on the other hand
was designed to be used in production
and we did put it in production at that
previous job
these modules also differ in terms of
dependencies parse file metadata is pure
pearl
text csv hashify wraps around the
existing text csv file which contains
some of its dependencies
and get reduced tests
obviously makes no sense if you're not
using git as your version control system
and it wraps around a
cpan module called get wrapper by john
anderson also known as gene hack
for its for its current implementation
now
i did this you can do this too
the first thing you have to do is
recognize when to step away from the
keyboard
and of course when you're doing this you
should ask is there an open source
solution already if so you use it
next if you there's no open source
solution you design the interface
this is what i call writing the
documentation first
then you write the tests in the code
and you get your tools ready that means
having an account on on cpan
which brian foy can do for you tonight
it is nice
and
yeah you want to share this code
so use a source code repository this
repository of choice these days is
github.com
thank you very much
just under 16 minutes oh very good
so any questions
isn't that get module shouldn't it be
under the app colon colon
um
there already are
several modules under the get high level
space including
i mean there are at least three that i
looked at
uh to use as a basis for this so i think
the use of this is as a top level thing
is
it's not an app it's a
scripting and phone to get it becomes a
demand right like all the other ones
yeah i mean it's a it's like uh don't
run it separately i think yet
no this this is a this is a comm
reduced test is a command line utility
right but uh it's just like say um
x utils module maker there is a cpan
distribution in this customary format
and one of the things in that cpan
distribution in the scripts directory is
a utility called module maker and when
you install it
the library gets installed to say
user local lib and the utility gets
installed to user local bin same way
here you install this
most of the
the library goes into a lib directory
and the utility itself goes into some
sort of does the library have a public
api or it's strictly for the internal
use of the slash bin part well
uh
it's all documented on cpan so you can
you can check it out
the question is because you're reducing
the number of tests wouldn't that make
the merge then invalid
but you're not merging this branch this
is a throwaway branch right you're
sending it you you you and it's useful
in situations
where you need results back before you
push the branch that is going to be code
reviewed and approved for merging it's
it's it's
it's for the developers it's not the
ultimate branch they'll get merged no
okay because for a second i was like
that sounds a little bit weird if you're
reducing tests before merging to the
main and now that sounds like you're
breaking the rules
it's a developer's tool right
any other questions
yes who gave text csv
you know i uh it was someone who
actually uh
looked at the module in the original
review process and sent me a patch to to
correct something and his complaint was
that the module wasn't fast well as i
said here to
i stated to you here to tonight the this
was intended to be a developer's tool
right i it's not i didn't use this uh in
production i used it it wasn't to make
production go faster it was to make the
developer go faster so uh
it's basically going to
uh
it's basically going to be as fast as
text csv and if you use the xs
implementation
then it's going to be fast enough but
it's
into two parts one was by coordinating
with the business manager first to make
sure that the specs were perfect before
you went and did the project
that was a good technique yeah i was
very glad that i did that and and uh
this module really
saved my ass there
because i you know i i got the i
i got the pure the the pearl solution in
like three hours time
the the sql that was like three weeks
time were you able to use your pro
source and designing the sql or just in
terms of the data structure there
uh
you know there was the actual pro code
useful in the sql is just really
basically the hashes i needed to create
in the process to get to the final
solution
suggested which temporary tables to
create
in terms of the data expansion
okay turn it back to charlie